just hours ago we learned that the
chicago teachers union voted to switch
to remote learning because of a surge in
covet cases prompting chicago public
schools to cancel classes wednesday
school is almost back in session here in
las vegas but with the omicron variant
spreading and the increased concern over
staffing shortages some local teachers
fear tomorrow's outcome madison
kimbrough spoke with some ccsd teachers
about their expert expectations for
their first day back madison
yeah brian while the teachers i spoke to
are happy to be teaching in person they
don't know exactly what they're going to
walk into tomorrow take a listen i guess
my biggest concern is the
you know the lack of staff i don't know
what's going to happen i don't know if
they're going to show up they're not
going to show up a topic on the minds of
many as ccsd teacher ashley mall shares
she says tuesday's work session was
eye-opening as many of her fellow
teachers were no-shows today was a staff
development day and we were all virtual
and there were
you know dozens of teachers out and you
know i i don't know the number tomorrow
but you know we're already covering you
know there's vacancies at our school the
school district aware of the staff
shortage by issuing this statement ccsd
will proactively monitor school staff
absences to deploy central service
personnel to assist at identified
schools if needed fellow ccsd teacher
jennifer bradley says the uncertainty of
what she and her colleagues may be
walking into wednesday is a bit
unsettling coming back from a break and
just getting you know
news of
how you know we're going to be even more
short staffed and very worried about
everything like
are they gonna tell us you know in one
day oh guess what you're online tomorrow
you know
should we get the kids prepared for that
as for how the district plans to monitor
covet 19 they assured students and staff
that mitigation strategies are in place
to protect the health of the students
and staff through their cleaning
protocols
and parents are asked to call the
hotline number up on your screen right
now if their child has positive for
covet 19. reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now